merci je vous le disais tout à l'heure
donc l'annoncé de la composition du
premier gouvernement rocard est donc
différé l'information a été confirmée
officiellement à l'elysée est ce qu'on a
d'autres précisions à l'hôtel matignon
rapide je vous aperçoit je pense que
vous nous entendez que nous vous
entendons bien là mais le temps et
j'espère que vous m'entendez oui henri
michel rocard france entend revenant
tout à l'heure de l'elysée le premier
ministre nous a lancé cette phrase toute
simple je ne vous ai jamais dit que
c'était pour ce soir et effectivement
michel rocard ne s'est attelé à la tâche
que depuis 24 heures depuis hier soir
il travaille beaucoup il voit pas mal de
monde notamment le président de la
république
ils téléphonent beaucoup également avant
d'établir sa liste définitive
cela étant dit il ya bien évidemment des
difficultés à résoudre des accords à
trouver avec l'elysée et puis des
susceptibilités à ménager notamment du
côté du parti socialiste cela étant dit
la nomination d'un nouveau premier
secrétaire du ps
interfel interfèrent tel pardon sur la
composition du gouvernement comme le
pensent certains
pas du tout vient de me dire à l'instant
à conseiller un très proche de michel
rocard
un proche de michel rocard qui m'a
simplement dit que la composition d'un
gouvernement prenait toujours un certain
temps alors michel rocard a toujours ici
à l'hôtel matignon il va travailler une
partie de la soirée et il se prépare à
une nouvelle journée aussi chargée que
celle d'aujourd'hui une journée que nous
avons vécu entre l'elysée matignon avec
jean-michel mercure sommes dans un
instant matignon ce matin dès 8h30
michel rocard a pris possession de son
bureau de premier ministre
celui-là même occupé hier encore par
jacques chirac seul collaborateur
officielle pour le moment jean paul
huchon son directeur de cabinet
occupation principale la formation du
gouvernement
rien de bien visible mise à part la
venue de pierre bérégovoy puis celle de
michel delebarre deux personnages très
certainement appelé à de hautes
fonctions
l'elysée 16h30 michel rocard vient
rencontrer le président de la république
pour lui soumettre ces projets une liste
de noms longuement examiné par les deux
hommes l'entretien durera une heure et
22 minutes
à sa sortie le premier ministre est
raccompagné par jacques attali le plus
proche conseiller de françois mitterrand
michel rocard ne fait aucune déclaration
mais sa façon ravie de poser devant la
sollicitation des photographes indique
qu'il n'est pas inquiet sur la formation
de son gouvernement
même s'il sait déjà qu'elle est remise à
demain à l'élysée l'instant d'après
françois mitterrand fait immortaliser
dans son bureau l'annoncé officielle par
robert badinter président du conseil
constitutionnel de sa réélection à la
présidence de la république